i'll read it to you
lavar
thank you
good night moon by margaret wise brown
pictures by clement heard
in the great green room there was a
telephone and a red balloon and a
picture of
the cow jumping over the moon
and there were three little bears
sitting on chairs
and
two little kittens and a pair of mittens
and a little toy house and
a young mouse
and a comb and a brush
and a bowl full of mush
and a quiet old lady who is whispering
[Music]
good night moon
[Music]
good night room
good night moon
good night cow jumping over the moon
[Music]
good night light and the red balloon
good night bears
good night cheers
[Music]
good night kittens
and
good nights
[Music]
good night clocks and good night socks
goodnight little house
and goodnight mouse
good night
calm and good night brush
[Music]
good night
nobody
good night mush
and good night to the old lady
whispering
hush
[Music]
good night stars
good night air
good night
noises
everywhere
uvar
yes
do you think when the cow says moo
you're really saying moon
[Music]
you